alors maintenant il ya un truc très dur
qui vous attend quoi
vous commencez tout le monde en parle
faut que ça se paye vous allez voir une
interview terrible l'interview la pire
l'interview upside down attention qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter de pire en
ce moment patrick que la jungle se
plante
quels défauts aimeriez-vous avoir volé
voleurs j'ai pas une gomme j'arrive pas
à voler sur donc
ah ouais ça n'a pas d'intérêt non mais
je me rend malade là non mais l'idée de
voler un truc ça me rend malade
j'aimerais parfois vole un oeuf déjà
passé par là vous allez paris vallier tu
m'entends gay
quelle est la qualité que vous regrettez
d'avoir crédules incroyable je crois
malheureusement beaucoup
enfin je crois beaucoup à l'eau aux gens
et à ce qu'on peut me direz par exemple
sur la jungle matthieu delaporte le
savez ça il me faisait croire m'a dit il
ya un acteur gérald laroche qui est
formidable dans le film qui fait loppsi
on dit faut que je fasse gaffe à pas
parler de l' affaire grégory les blacks
c'est le le frère de bernard laroche
et quand il est arrivé la première fois
je le regardais beaucoup de compassion
et voilà donc j'ai dû annuler
qu'est-ce que vous n'avez jamais dit à
personne
tu suces way s'est jamais dit ça mais
oui avec s'il te plaît tu s'il te plaît
mais tu suces six mois en grand - voilà
et suce moi c'est alors encore moins moi
c'est sucer général ouais tous sexes
confondus labadie j'allais général est
ce que je suis c'est tromper mon dieu
c'est vrai alors est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper car ça ouais c'est regard qu'il
allait demander qui ne voudriez vous pas
avoir comme femme dominique de villepin
en ce moment le derby il faudrait aller
voir l'agenda
déjà l entrée sais pas si ça marcherait
pas
c'est mauvais non mais il veut plein gré
un film qui ne passeraient pas qu'ils en
parlent
quels sont les défauts que doit avoir
une femme pour qu'elle vous séduisent
qu'elle soit plus grande que moi à
quelle est l'insulté qui vous a fait le
plus plaisir quand je jouais chico et
une fois un mec qui m'a dit un
producteur qui m'a dit que quand on a
pas marre de faire ta p'tite [ __ ]
brésilienne ouais donc voilà je trouve
ça classe parce que ma [ __ ] c'est bah
non c'est du jeune magicienne l'angola
et et petit oui senna sait pas quel
compliment qui vous énerve le plus quand
un mec arrive tu ne l'as pas vu depuis
dix ans et qui de fait n'a pas changé
ouais ça c'est très énervant non moi
j'ai envie de changer si tu préfère
qu'on dise voilà qu'est ce que tu as
pris ton oui par exemple mais je préfère
se trouve mieux maintenant il ya dix ans
et côté les gens n'a pas changé c'est
eric voir hier quoi cet arrière
mais d'où te vient cette joie de vivre
guy parce que c'est comme un négatif 1
c'est incroyable a électrisé le public
là qu'est la meilleure mauvaises
critiques qu'on vous ait fait la
meilleure mauvaises critiques bien binic
lite quoi ouais écrite par quelqu'un
qu'on respecte de vaguement ben mouaïa
mais qu'avait dit renaud matignon dans
le figaro quand j'ai commencé la télé il
avait dit ardisson arrive du néant et
après deux heures de plus il y retourne
c'est superbe c'est super bien écris tu
peux rien dire ah oui c'était donc mon
père ce héros à l'époque de mon père ce
héros est un journal qui s'appelait
guêpier sur ce il existe toujours
journal les petites [ __ ] pas et les
qui disait pourtant nous percevons et
que ce film n'a vraiment aucun intérêt
si ce n'est l'acteur patrick pan pan
dans le mille olabe
le
bien